Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Five, Episode Seven: the performing arts.
The performing arts, scenekunst, include a number of different genres: drama, ballet, opera, musical and revue.
What the different genres of the performing arts have in common is that they are performed here and now in front of an audience.
And as is the case with other art forms, Danish performing arts are also inspired from abroad.
In the 1700s, the Danish-Norwegian Ludvig Holberg, who lived from 1684 to 1754, was encouraged to write comedies for the theatre.
He became so gripped by the work that in a few years he wrote 25 comedies, where fun is made of citizens, peasants and noble people.
Often it is a clever maidservant who thinks up a plot against the unreasonable people of the comedy.
One of the most performed comedies is Erasmus Montanus from 1723, where the student Rasmus travels from Copenhagen home to his old parents and his waiting fiancée and boasts about his Latin learning.
Holberg was the first to write comedies in Danish, and the comedies are still often played on Danish stages.
At the beginning of the 1800s, the performing arts were renewed.
The Romantic poets used drama to express great passions and feelings.
They found motifs in history, in folk tales and folk songs.
Exotic and fairy-tale material was also important, and the leading National Romantic poet, Adam Oehlenschläger, was inspired by the Arabian tales of One Thousand and One Nights when in 1805 he wrote the fairy-tale play Aladdin eller Den Forunderlige Lampe, "Aladdin or the Wonderful Lamp", about the young boy Aladdin, who gets hold of an old lamp that turns out to be able to fulfil all his wishes.
The play is set in Middle Eastern surroundings, but is also a description of people and types in the Copenhagen of the time.
It was sought after among authors to write for the theatre.
Drama was regarded as the most distinguished art form.
The Royal Theatre, Det Kongelige Teater, became an important cultural institution.
Johan Ludvig Heiberg, who lived from 1791 to 1860, together with his wife Johanne Luise Heiberg, 1812 to 90, was prominent here.
He became director and author for the stage, while she was an admired actress.
They made themselves noticed not least within the French-inspired genre vaudeville, where drama and music are united in comedies, often about love entanglements among the young of the middle class.
In the time of Oehlenschläger and Heiberg, ballet became a leading part of the performing arts.
The choreographer August Bournonville, who lived from 1805 to 79, produced his version of an Italian ballet, La Sylphide, Sylfiden, which was first performed at the Royal Theatre in 1836.
His choreography is the only one that has survived.
Sylfiden is thereby one of the world's oldest surviving ballets.
Sylfiden has a romantic plot about a young Scottish man, James, who on his wedding day runs away with a sylph, that is, an invisible woman of air.
Bournonville has internationally had enormous importance for ballet as an art form.
His tradition was continued and renewed in the 20th century.
Flemming Flindt, who lived from 1936 to 2009, has also helped give Danish ballet great reputation abroad.
Together with the rock musicians in Savage Rose he created, for example, the ballet Dødens triumf, "The Triumph of Death", in 1971.
The ballet delighted with its strong criticism of a society on its way to doom, and it also caused outrage when several dancers performed naked.
In January 1939, eight months before the Second World War started, Kjeld Abell, who lived from 1901 to 61, had his play Anna Sophie Hedvig premiere at the Royal Theatre.
The play is about the teacher Anna Sophie Hedvig, who during a visit to her family in Copenhagen tells that she has killed the cruel and tyrannical headmistress Mrs Møller.
Anna Sophie Hedvig is a political play, where Kjeld Abell indirectly calls for resistance to fascism and Nazism.
The poet-priest Kaj Munk, who lived from 1898 to 1944, and who was murdered by Nazis in 1944, wrote his drama Niels Ebbesen when he had settled accounts with his own sympathies for Nazism.
The play is based on a folk song about the young Jutland nobleman Niels Ebbesen, who in 1340 kills one of the great German counts to whom Denmark was pawned.
The play was printed and banned in 1942 and only performed in 1945.
With the story of Niels Ebbesen Munk wanted to rouse Danes to resistance against Nazism and the German occupying power.
It was not only in plays, but to a great extent also through the revues that artists expressed resistance to Nazism.
Even though censorship was introduced during the occupation, the revue writer Poul Henningsen succeeded in smuggling a call to resistance into Kjeld Abell's revue Dyveke, from 1940, where Liva Weel, who lived from 1897 to 1952, sang Poul Henningsen's song "Man binder os på mund og hånd", "They bind us hand and mouth".
It was apparently a song about free love, but the audience could not be in doubt that the message was resistance and solidarity around ideals of freedom.
The text was later sung and released by the band Outlandish in 2004.
Danish performing arts after the Second World War have made themselves felt within different genres.
A forerunner of today's stand-up comedy was the Danish-American Victor Borge's shows, who lived from 1909 to 2000, with comedy and music.
He had great success in the USA with his one-man show Comedy in the Music, which was performed over 800 times on Broadway in New York from 1953 to 56.
In the 1960s and 70s, TV theatre became popular, especially with Leif Panduro's dramas, who lived from 1923 to 77, about conflicts in the family and between generations in a period of growing prosperity in Denmark.
People gathered around the TV screens when Panduro's plays were shown.
One of the best is Farvel Thomas, from 1968, about a man who ends up in a deep crisis and loneliness when he gets divorced.
Line Knutzon, born 1965, has since the 1980s and 1990s helped renew the art of drama.
Her drama is satirical, socially critical and very funny.
It is especially her ability to make lines absurd and crazy that makes her plays come alive.
Her first bigger success is the play Først bliver man jo født, from 1994, which takes place among residents in a stairwell of apartments.
The musical genre, which combines traditional drama and dialogue with music and dance, became popular from the end of the 1970s and onwards.
The musician and composer Sebastian, born 1949, has written music for some of the genre's biggest successes on Danish ground such as Skatteøen, from 1986, and Ronja Røverdatter, from 1991.
The last is based on a story by the Swedish children's book author Astrid Lindgren.
And with the popularity of the stand-up genre in the present, the performing arts have got new genres that appeal to a large audience.
In so-called stand-up comedy, the comedian stands on the stage and tells jokes and entertaining stories directly to the audience.
Among the best-known Danish stand-up comedians are Casper Christensen, born 1968, Anders Matthesen, born 1975, and Nikolai Stokholm, born 1990.
Here is your recap for Episode Seven.
Performing arts include drama, ballet, opera, musical and revue.
Holberg wrote 25 comedies, and was the first to write comedies in Danish; Erasmus Montanus is from 1723.
Oehlenschläger wrote Aladdin in 1805.
The Heibergs were prominent at the Royal Theatre.
August Bournonville's Sylfiden, first performed in 1836, is one of the world's oldest surviving ballets.
Flemming Flindt created Dødens triumf in 1971.
Kjeld Abell's Anna Sophie Hedvig premiered in January 1939.
Kaj Munk, murdered by Nazis in 1944, wrote Niels Ebbesen.
Poul Henningsen smuggled a call to resistance into the 1940 revue Dyveke, sung by Liva Weel.
Victor Borge's Comedy in the Music ran over 800 times on Broadway from 1953 to 56.
Leif Panduro wrote Farvel Thomas in 1968.
Line Knutzon, Sebastian's musicals, and stand-up comedians Casper Christensen, Anders Matthesen and Nikolai Stokholm round out the picture.